[Music]
thank you
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's week eight everybody and we are
live I'm here with my man Sam Richmond
producer Ryan my name is Greg Ivory
producer game going on right now we need
updates we need updates can you give us
some updates on that game yes sir it is
10-7 Jaguars at half against the Denver
Broncos
um as somebody who bet on Travis etn uh
Trevor Lawrence throwing an interception
at the one yard line uh was brutal so
I'm gonna try and put a smile on my face
for the next 30 minutes but it'll be
tough
hey what's the live line can you can you
give us a take on the live line yeah uh
the live line is uh Jags minus three
which uh I think is a hammer
Russell Wilson series
producer Ryan just said you guys [ __ ]
hamrid uh you guys typed in the comments
see if you guys would let us know if you
were riding with the Jaguars which way
should we go there uh but let's get
right to it let's not waste any time
we're here for a reason this man to the
net to the to the the the the the right
of me if you're looking at the screen
Sam Richmond is the sharp the guru of
the BR betting team and he has six picks
Sam
we want to know
what's the six picks today brother
45 seconds into it it says 10 seconds
this is conspiracy against me fix the
clock thank you thank you 45 seconds
we'll get that correct all right there
it is 45 seconds Sam take it away
all right we are going to start with the
Patriots minus two and a half
um look I have faded the New York teams
last week they owned me congratulations
to New York and everyone dming me about
how much of an idiot I am for fading New
York but I'm going to do it again uh I
really like this is a bounce back spot
for the Patriots
um I I think the biggest thing that
people are undervaluing is just how much
Breece Hall meant to this Jets team he
was pretty much the only reason why
their offense was successful without him
I think it's going to be tough sledding
this patch team has looked pretty good
outside last week so I'll bylaw in the
Pats I'll fade New York and I'll let the
haters key off on me again
there it is Sam's fade in New York uh
haters haters are gonna hate everybody
don't have haters Sam I'm taking up some
of your time because you were real real
real brief with that one but I like it
if I can sum up what happened during my
talking
um a computer update came up on my
screen so I could not see what was going
on uh so I didn't know if I was close to
time or over the time I was like I'm
just gonna stop talking because I do not
want to get yelled at for going over so
I was like I'm just going to play it
safe but um but I can continue if you
want
no no no no no no we want your next pick
but first we got to get to the chat
thank you for playing it safe though Sam
thank you for playing it safe and fading
New York all right Ryan come back in
here bro cause you are
our connection you were me and Sam
connection to the chat what are they
saying Sam getting some love or hate
from the New York crowd out on New York
what do you think uh Cayman saying he's
keeping the receipts it's Jets money
line all day uh Scotty Griggs saying
Jets moneyline uh
ls-44 Jets money line all day uh we've
got locklord Steelers spread plus 11 and
a half lock of the day uh Jay Wade
fading me saying Broncos live plus three
and a half bet on Russell Wilson at your
own risk man you do that
uh who was Wilson at your own risk ah
yeah I prayed before I bet on Russell
Wilson me personally like you've got to
get a prairie embedding on that guy yeah
you need to pray uh I want to win is
trying to forecast he's trying to jump
ahead we've done seven weeks of this
show he thinks he knows what Sam's gonna
pick he says Washington has to be one of
Sam's picks today
well last week that was one of my few
wins last week that's true the commies
against the poverty Packers yeah uh Al
Mendoza CMC anytime TD today uh I love
that you're not getting you're not
getting love from the New York crowd
I'm too off right there brother I
appreciate you you're gonna send you
back to the chat and we're gonna put the
spotlight back on Sam Richmond because
Sam you're the reason why we're here six
Best Bets you gave us one five more to
go give me 45 seconds on the clock there
it is Sam take it away
all right we are taking the Lions plus
four as my other pick
um this Line's offense is finally
getting healthy
um I think people again probably forget
how good this offense looked at the
beginning of the year and they had their
dudes they're getting Swift back they're
getting Saint Brown back I think that
matters a lot especially against the
Dolphins team that isn't super
impressive uh defensively I think their
20th overall and defensive dvoa we need
like a little beat for the dvo I
mentioned uh but that that Dolphins
defense isn't really good they don't get
after the quarterback which I think sets
up really nicely for Jared Goff now the
Lions defense does totally stink total
hand up so the Dolphins will put up some
points but giving me four points at home
with the lions having their guys back uh
I'll take that
hey right on time right on time my man
Sam rich I didn't get an update then so
I I felt good about that
I love the points that you brought up
there that that that Lions team early on
they that that offense was was not
injured they were clicking they were
clicking uh
that's two Sam that's two picks we got
four more to go
let's just jump right into this next one
45 seconds on the clock Sam take it away
all right we are taking Houston Texans
money line I know it's gross it is one
of the grossest picks on the board today
the Texans stink I won't try and say
that they're good but I do think this is
a really good spot to fade the Titans on
the road in a divisional game where that
familiarity matters with a rookie
quarterback having to start Vegas first
start on the road
um I think everyone looks at this game
and just thinks hey the rookie
quarterback doesn't matter that much
because they're just going to give it to
Derek Henry a million times which they
will but that becomes super predictable
right the tax sends their run defense
isn't very good but if they know they're
running a million times the game they're
going to stack the box and for all the
talk about the Titans run offense 22nd
overall and run defense run off in
Stevia so it hasn't even been that good
so I like Texans today
there it is Sam said he likes the sex
and Sam we are in Houston I mean
stadium is probably like a couple a
couple minutes away we can go catch this
one live if you want but uh yeah in two
hours right when this show's over I
gotta Sprint over to the airport so I I
cannot attend but I hope you make it out
there
uh Hey Texas money live Sam likes it
rookie quarterback I see the dots
connected and I see the dots connecting
Sam but that's three picks three picks
that's all we're doing and we're looking
for Scoops scoops and dots Scoops and
Dots here we go three picks in three
more to go Sam
you got 45 seconds on the clock
talk to me all right I feel like I come
on the show every week and I take the
Seahawks and I say the same thing every
week and I'm gonna say it again like I
think the Seahawks team is legitimately
really good we're so we're deep enough
into the season where it's not a fluke
this offense is amazing Geno Smith is a
fringe MVP candidate I know it's crazy
to say Kenneth Walker is just an
absolute monster and is a real Contender
for Rookie of the Year this team is just
really really good and I'm going to be
careful here because I don't want to
give any more ammo to New York who
already hates me but yes I I'm not a big
believer in this Giants team I think
going on the road to Seattle against a
good Seahawks team is where they finally
slip up but if they don't I'm sure I
will hear about it from a million people
no the giant I mean the Giants are gonna
go to the 12 today like that's that's an
atmosphere
and if you if they win that game Sam
like we I'll have to give it to them
I think this is a yep you know what I'm
saying they they've done their thing
since you know we were in what week
eight
they've done their thing up to week
eight they're respectable they go into
Seattle and continue to do their thing
and then come out with a victory hey you
gotta respect that Giants team you're
just gonna have to tip your cap and
respect that Giants team but we will
have to see we will have to see I think
that them going to the 12
that's a tough tough tough tag so we
will see what happens out there in
Seattle but Sam that's four picks four
picks two more to go
can we get 45 seconds on the clock
please
here we go Sam there it is take it away
all right next pick we are taking Saints
plus two I think the line is at one
right now I'm totally fine with it Greg
I think you're gonna be with me here
just in the sense of the Raiders are so
overvalued and just so over hyped like I
don't know why everyone is so high in
this Raiders team they're two and four
they don't really have that great of a
statistical profile
um I know everyone wants to make a big
deal about Andy Dalton's thinking
um past week but they actually moved the
ball really well against the Cardinals
he just had some awful interceptions if
he doesn't do that uh I I like that
offense I like Kamara I like what
they've been doing and again I just I
just don't think this Raiders team
warrants this type of respect that
they're getting so I'll take the Saints
at home in a must-win spot for them to
keep their season alive
there it is Sam yeah I'm like you I
don't understand why this Raiders team
is being put on a pedestal it's probably
the the Devonte Adams effect but
their defense is still the Raiders
defense
I mean last week they played the Texans
you know it's the Texans so the Texans
but that defense is still the Raiders
defense and uh
yeah they're like the 30th their 30th in
defensive dboa there's my DBA counter
like 29th and past defense evoa like
it's it's really bad they cannot stop
anyone it sounds like a Raider defense I
mean it it sounds like the Raiders and
that and that's what I tell everybody if
you go to my Instagram I tell them the
Raiders will be the Raiders every every
week the Raiders will be the Raiders uh
but they're going into New Orleans that
is a tough place that is a tough place
to go get a w
Saints plus money
on the road I mean at home love it Sam
hey let's let's bring in producer Ryan
let's bring in producer Ryan
come back bro talk to us is the chat
popping what they talking about is Sam
getting love
or is there hate well the Sam's uh
Patriots pick has set off uh I like the
Pats I wonder which team he supports uh
in all caps the Jets actually suck Then
followed it up with after Sam picked the
Saints finally a good pick
s if he likes the Pats he would have
liked the minus two and a half no
I'm confused I'm just glad to go one for
five in terms of the audience liking my
pick so there you go well we'll try and
keep it going uh D.L Carlton has a
question for you though Sam he says when
was the last time the Lions scored a
touchdown
they got their guys back they got their
advice and they actually moved the ball
again pretty well against the Cowboys I
think they're like 5.6 yards per play
um and the Dolphins just don't get after
the quarterback and if you give golf
time if you give him golf time let that
man cook so no he's not that great but
he does have some really good weapons so
um I uh I do like the lines uh corbu
saying Seahawks over Giants Geno gonna
cook with Walker serving it up uh so he
likes your Seahawks there uh wavy baby
bears plus 10 is a no-brainer today
guys
we're not we're not really betting on
Justin fields of the Chicago Bears today
right this is the Cowboys I'm not no
yeah this is the Cowboys here uh we've
got OG Masa saying Pat's offense is
trash Jets D gonna have a field day uh
disagree and then bully season saying
tease Las Vegas to plus four and a half
so likes a close one there
um but there you go that's the chat here
there it is appreciate you producer Ryan
shout out to everybody in the chat Sam
five down one more to go 45 seconds is
on the clock and please please please
talk to me nice
uh I'm sorry Greg I'm gonna lose you
here but I every time the Niners and
Rams play together I always take the
Niners but I'm actually going the other
way this time around look I think for me
the the big thing here is the loss of
Debo Samuel which I just think is
absolutely massive he is the heart and
soul of that offense everything revolves
around him even when he isn't catching
the ball or running with the ball it all
flows through him
um and I just think they're going to be
in trouble today without him yes they
have McCaffrey but this is a game where
you're going to need Jimmy G to do some
things without Debo and I just don't see
it and look I've been really high on
this Niners team but they got absolutely
shredded defensively by the Chiefs last
week and I know Stafford is not Mahomes
but nine yards per play well if that
defense is not top two top three and
Jimmy G has to actually win games for
the Niners I I know I went over but I'm
I'm a little worried about them
yes Sam you make some valuable valuable
valuable points uh Devo Samuel is out
today and that's that's that's gonna
take a hit on the offense but you
mentioned Christian McCaffrey but you
didn't mention Christian McCaffrey
enough
Christian McCaffrey is
a superstar and and and he in his own
right can carry this offense but I want
you to I just I just want you to pay
attention I agree with that but I do
think it's going to take some time for
him to get integrated fully that's
that's that's all I'll say well I I
agree if you go look at his uh his yards
per carry last year he was he had a
decent decent out outing yes last week
barely known the offense so give him
this week knowing the offense but but my
point is here Sam
the Niners have beat the Rams
I think I want to say seven consecutive
regular season games and they've done it
in many many ways it wasn't just because
of Debo
so remember that George Kittle remember
that today let's move on though let's
move on let's bring producer Ryan back
into the fold uh because it's time it's
time to uh talk anytime touchdown scores
anytime touchdown scores I got into this
bet really to be honest I got into this
bet last season but I absolutely love
this season because this is a bet where
you could just like look almost look on
the schedule and be like who's going to
score today who's do who is due for a
touchdown you can get your money when
they score but uh I'm gonna boost it
anytime TouchDown for you guys today
Ryan talk to the people let's pull up
those odds
all right most bet anytime TD no
surprise at number one Derrick Henry in
his career has absolutely cooked to
Houston Texans and I mean cooked the
Houston Texans so he's up there at minus
140 that's pretty good value Tony
Pollard number two at -145 know Ezekiel
Elliott today the Cowboys are going to
lean on Pollard number three saquon
Barkley number four Josh Jacobs who's
having an unbelievable year we jump back
down to the bottom of Dalvin cook minus
145 and then to round it all out on
Sunday night football against the Green
Bay Packers we have Mr Stefon Diggs at
minus
110. drop your locks in the comments we
need to know who we're gonna boost we
need to know your picks your locks we'll
grade them later on in the show but we
need to boost the pick so drop it in the
chat Greg Sam I also need your locks
like I need air so please give it to me
I'll go first Justin Jefferson lock it
in they're at home Kirk Cousins Michael
Ritter will like that Kirk Cousins yes
Kirk give the ball to Justin Jefferson
today and go get that tub is that minus
125 I think this is the best it's been
all year that's true well there was plus
money a few weeks ago we forget that I
cashed that so that's less money Justin
Jefferson in London in London
and you didn't tell me no I happened
right after the show it happened right
after the show I'm the London Whisperer
man that's what they call me
Sam what do you like
I'm taking I'll go Nick Chubb uh it's a
boring pick
um but I he's just a monster and I like
a little Monday night anytime TD so I'm
taking Nick show I think he leads the
league with eight touchdowns so and he's
just been on absolute fire and who else
I'm gonna give the ball to
Ryan
let's make a decision you are a chat
whisper so what is the chat saying are
they filling up those comments with some
picks that we should be uh thinking
about or did they take JJ did they take
Justin Jefferson or Sam's pick
yeah so we've got a Eddie in here saying
Tony Pollard anytime TD is a lock and
has three lock emojis uh didn't go to
four or five though so you don't really
know how much of a lock that really is
uh I want to win Tony Pollard is a lock
green ranger riding with you Greg Justin
Jefferson
uh Chief nub digs we've got uh Moody
baby Devante Adams against the Saints
uh a lot of Tony Pollard a lot of Justin
Jefferson but quite frankly a lot of
Devonte Adams in here so Greg
should we do some should we do some
magic
yeah we we do some magic but before we
do some magic let us pray because we
know Devonte Adams play for
play for sure
well what what what what's going on in
uh New Orleans today but before actually
Good Vibes good box let me do my magic
all right here we go I'm gonna boost
that I'm gonna boost that Devonte Adams
from minus 155 to plus 110 poof just
like that the magic has happened you
guys see it
you guys see it now let us pray again
because we know Devonte Adams and the
Raiders are taking on those Saints and
uh we'll see how they how they match up
against that Saints defense uh make sure
you guys tell us on DraftKings right
Ryan yeah you can tell us on DraftKings
go go to our social Pages we'll have the
link click on the link it'll boost it to
plus 110 and then we're gonna make some
money together so that'll be fun that'll
be a good time Good Vibes love when we
make money together love won't make what
happened in Vegas I don't know what
happened in Vegas but uh there's always
another time we don't talk about it
don't talk about it there's always
another time all right guys you guys see
up there you know coming up next yeah
it's it's Greg's pick so here we go here
we go keep dropping your locks keep
dropping those picks in the chat I'm
gonna give y'all my favorite play today
now I just got an update from the
producer that the line changed and this
is literally a reason why I was betting
this game uh the commanders they're
taking on the coats the coats Sam
Ellinger they he's the quarterback now
he's taken over from Matt Ryan uh
younger quarterback younger younger
quarterback
so I like this game guys this game is
going to be a low scoring game low
scoring game so the reason I am choosing
the commanders is because I'm banking on
this one being a low scoring game the
over under is not even at 40. over under
is not even at 40s so I see this one
being a close one right now the line is
two and a half I say buy it up to three
and a half buy it up to three and a half
play the close game take the commanders
play the close game buy it up to three
and a half I like it two and a half yeah
but buy it up to three and a half I like
it uh Ryan talk to me what are the
audience talking about what are they
saying in the chat well Greg I just need
to address something real quick I've
been seeing some people on Twitter who
hate the idea of buying the hook
why why you get get yourself some value
I love buying the hook so I'm all on
board with you here I love buying the
hook
worried about you guys oh Sam's anti
Sam's that's high that's that's
unfortunate yeah that's that's tough
not shocking though uh should we grade
some bets guys
let's get to it good all right let's do
it uh we've got the onions saying please
grade my bed Chris olave over five and a
half perceptions that's plus money plus
115. foreign
that's that's the highest I give
um super talented against the poverty
past defense love love love
I have a question if somebody jumped in
here and said Pat's minus two and a half
would you give it a day
yes because I bet it so if it's in the
six bets and so that's an a that's the
only way you're getting that okay
uh almendoza CMC anytime touchdown Plus
105.
love it yeah I I obviously I like the
Rams today but I do think we see this a
lot when teams get like a new weapon
they like to get them involved in the
red zone to get them like we I remember
last year we cashed a lot of Odell Ram
stuff because they would just feed him
in the red zone to make him feel good so
uh I think you're gonna see that the
Niners are going to get CMC involved in
trying to get him in the end zone yeah
my man uh Kyle Shanahan made a comment
earlier in the week he said uh
Christopher McCaffrey's good to go he
knows the whole Playbook so unleash
they're gonna unleash CMC today
uh Luis happy Arizona plus three and a
half against the Minnesota Vikings
I don't know yeah that game that game
was yeah that game was a stay away for
me so I'll give it like a a c
um I'm pretty out on this Cardinals team
but the getting Hopkins back matters a
lot I'm out in the Cardinals team but
I'm also out on Kirk Cousins so uh you
get like a c for me Greg what's your
take yeah I'm I'm around there too Sam
I'm around there too I I
I was leaning more towards Vikings money
line to be honest rather than the spread
but like you said that Cardinals team
there's there's just too many ups and
downs and question marks around them for
me to put my money on them so
I'm staying away uh uh from that bet
particularly and I'll give it a c
all right we've got a parlay in here a
parlay that I I just built so we could
see the odds that people could see the
odds this is good because I don't know
if we've talked about in the show yet
but our our good friend Greg Ivory
actually cashed a parlay last night so
the parlay King will grade the parlay
start off the show with this
I'm finding this out now
great that's huge
that's huge uh all right lock Lord Jamal
Williams anytime TD Derrick Henry
anytime TD like we said Cook's the
Texans and Josh Jacobs anytime TD you
see it right here on the screen
plus five plus five sixty one so again
Jamal Williams Derrick Henry Josh Jacobs
plus 561. what do you guys think
Jamal Williams scares me but everything
else I like it
yeah that's just my cake as well
that's me being honest like every every
parlay has to have that one that is like
the diceiest leg and if it hits you're
in a great spot uh or it's gonna fail
you miserably so you gotta take a risk
with at least one leg
CMC in for Jamal Williams that's pretty
lucky
I like what you did there yeah uh all
right I Silva Eagles minus 11 and a half
oh man
um I'm so out on the Steelers team I
think they're so bad I have trouble
taking double digit favorites in this
league just because of how much parody
there is
um but I do lean towards Philly because
I just think the Steelers team stinks
tell you like a bee
B minus
Fly Eagles Fly we don't we don't say
that on the show we don't sit take it
back that's all that's all I'm gonna say
it's Fly Eagles Fly I do not believe in
that that Steelers offense like yeah
maybe we can please your boy Mitch
trubisky failed you Greg and now now
you're going the other one yeah
fortunately in Mitch we do not
don't blame you
that first week though week one man we
were on top of the world with that
week one we thought we thought they were
going to the Super Bowl we beat the
Bengals himself
we've got Jay mares in here Damien
Pierce plus 110 anytime TD against the
Titans
love love Damon Pierce guy
big Damian Pierce guy guys a guy's a
tank uh b-plus what were the odds plus
110 Plus 110.
the only tough part is how many times
the Texans gonna get in the end zone but
if they do get in the end zone it's
probably going to appears
all right yeah I like that he ran the
ball hard last week he's really good
he's young guys
see him getting it done
um we've got the onions back in the chat
Josh Allen over
a half an interception so just to throw
one
oh
against the pack I don't know what are
the odds that I'm sure you didn't listen
yeah no of course he didn't so I'll I'll
go look
yeah it's tough to say fully without the
odds but
um I don't know man that game is I'm
that game scares me just in general
because the Packers have been awful and
I do think the bills will crush them but
then you're like 11 points are there in
Rogers like feels like you got to take I
don't know that game that game put a
pretzel in my mind so I'm not betting it
uh but the odds are Plus 120.
uh
I'm probably taking place
I'll take that over for the value one
ride with the commenter I love it
tit ball you know what I mean
plus money yep
um thanks to Greg we now have a lot of
Fly Eagles Fly in this chat that's my
worst nightmare uh Mr benis Jonathan
Taylor who has not been good this year
but also the Cults have not been good
this year anytime TD
I mean again rookie quarterback or not a
rookie quarterback but first time
quarterback making it start like they're
gonna rely on Taylor a lot the Colts I
just I don't I actually think they're
going to be better with Alger over met
Ryan Ryan is so bad and they couldn't
and our teams were able to actually load
the Box they know that Ryan can't throw
the ball over 10 yards so I actually
think having alinger in there who's
going to be able to throw the ball deep
might open things up for Taylor
but I this Colts team again is just like
I just I I just wanted to stay away from
games involving them until I see
something because they've just been so
weird
yeah Ellen you're taking over uh I think
linger's gonna be more of a playmaker
than Matt Ryan he's going to be running
outside of the pocket he's going to be
running for rush yards himself so he's
going to be making plays uh
but I still think this one like I said
in my point my previous point I still
think one's going to be a close one I
think this one's going to be a real
close dog fight of a game low scoring
Jonathan Taylor hmm
I'm giving that one a b b he could get
he could get in the end zone he could
but with it being low scoring the odds
you know huh
yeah where you guys are tough graders
this is this is difficult for me to try
and get the chat and a here uh Mike
Ritter's in here uh spamming the chat
with Devonte Flu Game uh Greg we were at
the Raiders game live last week
sometimes the man just disappears
oh he doesn't disappear
devante's was losing he was losing his
Defender he was an open space the whole
game I was literally I told Michael
Ritter I said hey I'm not even watching
the game I'm watching Devante Adams I'm
watching the poetry in motion out there
and my man with his feet is just poetry
out there on the football field so
Devonte Adams wasn't he wasn't going Mia
just the ball you know he has to get the
ball the ball has to end up in his hands
you know no I I agree I mean the man's
open all game we need Derek Carr to look
his way uh but we'll do one last grader
bet here uh you can call me biased
that's okay that's fine uh that's easy
Dack over 238 passing yards today minus
142.
I agree
yeah you're you're a big decator why are
you like acting like you're about to
give an over you're gonna say under me
yeah no no no no no no I'm not I'm not
acting like I'm gonna give it over this
is a hammer under spot Hammer maybe like
110 yards
Hammer the younger very anti-dak guy so
yeah no I hate this pick I would give it
an F minus but I'm not the greater you
guys are
well I'll I'll let you give that grade
so hey hey on that note on that note I'm
going under because that got improve
some stuff that finger has to prove that
it's healthy to me but on that note man
on that note Sam we got your six Best
Bets I took the commanders by by a point
buy two you know it's going to be a
close game
and then producer Ryan's giving out F
minuses on Dax over I love it I
absolutely love it guys it's been fun
week eight let's go get rich we're
sending all Good Vibes to you guys in
the chat my name is Greg Ivory for
producer Ryan and Sam the guru Richmond
we are leaving
we're out of here peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]